hello everyone and welcome to this super
amazing and informative video on content
delivery Network or in short CDN if you
have ever experienced slow website
loading times or if you have wondered
why some web pages take longer to access
than others than you are in the right
place in this video we are going to
explain what content delivery networks
are how they work and why they are so
important cdns are Global networks of
servers that work together to deliver
content to user faster and more
efficiently the commonly used by
websites and applications to offer the
workload from there on web servers which
can lead to improved performance and
scalability by Distributing content
across numerous servers and locations
cdns can provide rapid access to users
worldwide regardless of their
geographical location wait but how
exactly do syrians work well when a user
requests content from a website or any
application the request is routed to the
nearest server on the CDN the server
then delivers the content directly to
the user resulting in Faster loading
times and because cdns are used multiple
servers they can handle large amounts of
traffic and Ensure High availability and
latency even during times of high demand
so why should you care about syrians
well they're becoming increasingly
critical to businesses and organizations
that rely on web-based content cdns can
help you improve your performance
achieve faster loading times and reduce
the cost of delivering content and with
many syrians offering cost-effective
Solutions there's really no reason why
you shouldn't be using one so grab onto
your seats and stay tuned with us until
the end of the session as we teach you
more about how syrians work and how you
can use them in your own business and
organizations let's dive into the agenda
of this session and before we begin if
you are someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security by
graduating from the best universities
for a professional who elicits to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts then try giving a show
to Simply learn postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
schwarzman College of Engineering the
link is mentioned in the description box
that will navigate you to the course
page where you can find a complete audio
of the program being offered and if
these are the types of videos you would
like to watch then hit the Subscribe
button like and press the Bell icon to
never miss on any updates and now we'll
see the agenda for today so first we'll
have an introduction to cdns and then
we'll see what is CDN then we'll see the
working of CDN and then we'll see why we
should use cdns and then the reliability
and redundancy of cdns so now let's get
started today's topic is very exciting
as these are the content delivery
networks or cdns so starting with have
you ever wondered how websites like
Facebook Netflix and Amazon manage to
deliver their content so quickly well
the answer is cdns or content delivery
networks so let's Dive Right In and
explore what cdns are all about so
content delivery Network or CDN is a
geographically distributed network of
servers that caches content close to end
users it's like having multiple copies
of a website stored in different
locations worldwide cdns help in
delivering internet content such as HTML
Pages JavaScript files style sheets
images and videos quickly and
efficiently and cdns work by placing
servers at strategic locations around
the world open at internet exchange
points these points are where different
internet providers connect to exchange
traffic by being closer to users cdns
reduce latency and improve website load
times so this is how exactly does a CDN
improve website load times so you can
see the origin server here and this is
the CDN server it's also called add
server so the users can just type in and
search for any content and they can
fetch it from the ad server that is the
static content once a time the CDN
server it fetches the content from the
origin server and it caches that data so
when a user like runs a query or search
for the content so it will get to the
CDN and it will fetch the static content
so after some time these static content
they also being fetched by the origin
server so if there's an update in the
origin server so CDM will after some
time they will also get that update so
this is how CDN works now we'll see why
we should use cdns or how they can
improve the website load times so first
is the minimize latency but before that
so cdns or content delivery networks are
like super fast highways on the internet
they store copies of all the words
pictures and videos You See online in
special servers spread across the world
that is called ad servers in this way
when you want to see something cdns
bring it to you from a nearby server
instead of the original far away place
so this is how CDN work now we'll see
why you should use cdns so the first
reason is that it minimize latency so
cdns minimize latency by reducing the
distance between users and website
resources instead of connecting to our
website's origin server users connect to
a nearby data center within the CDN the
shorter distance results in Faster
service secondly cdns employ various
hardware and software optimizations they
use efficient load balancing techniques
and solid state hard drives to ensure
data reaches the user as quickly as
possible thirdly CDN schedules file
sizes through tactics like minification
and file compression smaller file sizes
mean quicker load times benefiting both
users and website owners lastly cdns
optimize TLS SSN certificates which
ensures security while speeding of
websites techniques like connection
reuse and TLS faults start make TLS or
SSL encrypted sites load faster now
let's talk about the reliability and
redundancy provided by cdns so cdns
distribute Network traffic evenly across
multiple servers ensuring scalability
during sudden spikes in traffic this
load balancing feature improves
reliability and prevents server from
becoming overwhelmed moreover cdns
employ intelligent failover mechanisms
if one or more servers go offline due to
Hardware malfunctions the traffic is
automatically redirected to other
operational servers ensuring
uninterrupted service in the rare event
of an entire data center experiencing
technical difficulties cdns use anycast
routing this technology transfers the
traffic to another available data center
guaranteeing continuous website
accessibility next is security it's a
top priority for cdns let's explore how
cdns protect data cdns enhance website
security by providing fresh SSL TLS
certificates these certificates ensures
strong authentication encryption and
integrity safeguarding user data and
maintaining a secure browsing experience
lastly let's talk about how cdns reduce
bandwidth cost for website owners cdns
minimize bandwidth consumption by
reducing the number of requests made by
the origin server by caching content at
the network Edge CDN serve content
directly from the servers reducing the
load on the original server and cutting
down hosting cost and there you have it
a Content delivery Network or CDN is a
powerful tool that enhances website
performance reduces bandwidth cost and
show reliability and improves security
whether you are a website owner or an
internet user cdns play a crucial role
in delivering a fast and seamless
browsing experience we hope you enjoyed
this video and gain a better
understanding of cdns if you found this
information helpful don't forget to like
And subscribe to our channel for more
exciting Tech related content as always
thank you for watching and with that we
have reached the end of this tutorial
and let's take a minute to hear from our
Learners who have experienced massive
success in their careers hi I'm Philip
I'm 61 years old and last year I upscale
was simply learns postgraduate program
in cyber security after working 30 years
in the IIT sector in various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course of
course I must say was packed with
practical examples it was led by highly
skilled certified instructors with many
companies before the security analysts
and the architect on a contract basis
but I needed some stability which I got
with the job I just started with Infosys
as a cyber security consultant happened
on the first and if you have any
questions please feel free to comment
and we'll have it answered for you as
soon as possible until next time thank
you for watching stay safe keep learning
and get ahead
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here